let's speak to marina lipvinenko she's
the widow of alexander lipvinenko and he
was killed
after being poisoned by radioactive
polonium
in a central london hotel thank you so
much for talking to us
this afternoon it must be particularly
difficult
for you to watch what's happening at the
moment
what was your first thought when you
heard about
mr navalny getting sick on that plane
first of all when i heard it two days
ago of course it was very
devastating alexey navalny was
very active and very critical to russian
regime
but he escaped from very serious
damages he was arrested he spent a lot
of time in custody
like 10 days 15 days but
it was not so much serious of course his
brother was arrested
and spent a few years in prison
but alexey navalny was more or less
safe and when i heard this news i was
very shocked
thought when there were reports that
he's been taken ill on a plane
flying to moscow
was that your initial thought
no first of all uh if you're talking
about how it's all happened he was
traveling from
siberia cities tomsk to moscow
and what happened to him it was so
unexplained
and plain need to be lent it just
emergency in another city
siberian city olmsk when he was stayed
for
two days but everybody understood it was
a very dangerous situation because
nobody believed he would be treated
in the right way and now we might be a
little bit safe
because we know he is a transported to
germany to berlin
and now he is under control of german
doctors
and this is a little bit easier to talk
about this situation
but i don't think we need to be relaxed
because we still don't know what
happened to alexey
yet what do you make of the doctor at
the obsc
hospital saying that it was something to
do with blood sugar
even more they say it is metabolic
disease
it's a quite strange of course it may be
symptoms like that
but i don't think is the reason why
alexa became
so extremely ill because of that
what doctors said again i can't be very
critical to them
but i don't think they'll be so much
freedom to say what they don't know
or if you're going back to my story
my husband alexander was treated in
hospital here in uk
and almost for two weeks but he would
recognize
he was poisoned by radioactive material
should i blame british doctors
not of course because nobody before was
poisoned by rather active
polonium and now we don't know what
happened to alexey
and as soon we will know what happened
to him and what
a poison or what the agent was used
against him
you could discuss what as a level of
order i mean who wanted to stop him to
neutralize or even to kill
and maybe we will see would be able
doctors in russia to recognize what
happened to alexey
we were just um showing the picture
there of your husband
um alexander when he was in hospital
after being
poisoned um here it is again on a on a
personal note
for you mourinho it must be difficult to
watch what's happening to navalny at the
moment
the most what i do feel is for
our family of alexey navalny his wife
his children and his parents what do
needs
as a great support not only russian
community and
international community as well you have
to have
a position as alexei navalny otherwise
it would be even more difficult to talk
to russia because they tried to
destroy any oppositions and we will not
have any truth from russia
because alexander he was not only a
positioner
he provided a lot of investigations he
was
providing a lot of documentaries about
corruption in russia
and we have some use and knowledge about
current situation
after that i don't know would be people
able
to do the same we need to save alexander
do you think it must have been a very
difficult decision
to get him on the plane and to leave
russia yes
his health is obviously very much at
risk his life is at risk but
knowing for his family that once he left
russia he may never return
exactly when i was asked before
about this situation uh he was forced to
leave
russia actually uh before he said this
many times they tried to
push him out from russia because they
don't need him
here in russia and now after this
situation when he left russia now he's
in germany
is a very difficult and very complicated
moment from one side
we know he's safe and now he might be
treated more perfectly and he will
save his life and maybe if even his
health
but would be he's able to go back to
russia is a big question
i hope you don't mind me asking this but
what was that decision like for your
husband he left in 2015 and came to the
uk and claimed asylum
um was that a very difficult decision
for him to make
first of all sasha left in 2000 and his
decision to leave country was to save
us his family our son who was six years
old
and sasha we have to say was a former
officer
of security service and when he saw what
is happening
in russia under putin's regime
already in 2000 he realized it would be
very dangerous place
and of course when he receives this all
black males
to his others and when he realized our
life not safe he decided to leave russia
what is your life like now you're in
sicily at the moment
um what is life like for you now
it's not a life in sicily it's a break
in sicily
and it was my just opportunity to take
this
break after coronavirus restrictions
and i'm still a british citizen i still
be
uh i'm still living london and i hope i
will be back soon
but in general i'm uh
in general in london what is life for
you having been through everything that
you've been through
what is life like first of all i never
expected
it will take so long time for fight for
justice
i can't say i've never been prepared
because nobody prepared for this
huge challenge but during this very long
journey i achieved some result what i'm
very proud
and sasha's name still be in memory of
people
of course in this very tragical context
what happened in london
in 2006 but in another context because
sasha
tried to say what might happen to russia
and he tried to
prevent this situation he couldn't he
was
i can't say alone but he was not
supported a lot but now
we understand what sasha tried to say it
was true
and my duty now to bring this to people
and help people not to make another
mistake what was made
20 years ago 10 years ago this is looks
like
what i can do for memory of sasha and
i'm doing this
um are you amazed then that we keep
seeing instances of
opposition leaders of people who are
anti-putin
being poisoned
it's again we need to look to russian
history more
deeply and russia
when it became as a new country after
soviet union collapsed
and everybody believed so many things
have changed
unfortunately not and long history of
killing people
of oppositioners of enemies
of critics we could see even
many years ago when it was a soviet
union and unfortunately
they still do it with these uh
oppositioners and with the critics of
this regime
and uh practice to poison people again
it's not in you
and we can count it my names how many
people been suffered
somebody died like my husband
somebody been stopped to do something
duty as a
prominent journalist for example anna
politkovska
when she was alive and she tried to make
a report
of this lan when children and parents
were hosted
at school another journalist was
poisoned and died
again in russia as a yuri shikha
teaching who was
provided a lot of very serious
investigation
and we still don't know who killed him
and why he was
killed and it's a lot it's a lot of
names
and recently a few years ago it was a
politician
vladimir murzar he was poisoned twice
and again not investigation was provided
in russia and we still don't
know actually who tried to kill him
and this new situation but looks like as
a row
of names of people who was poisoned
attempted to poison and of course i
don't need to remind you what happened
in 2018
when was used a novichok nerve agent
and when not just two people been
attempted to poison
when all city was as a hostages
because agent anovichok it's extremely
dangerous
and it doesn't matter how many times it
would be on the surface
it'd still be very dangerous and all
city was suffered
and i think it's a messages again and
again
you need to understand it's a very
serious
situation and this regime in russia
it's a poisoned and you
sometimes need to be very accurate when
you have a business with this regime
given what happened in 2018 mourinho are
you ever worried about your own safety
you know
um what happened to people in salisbury
and we remember don sturgeon who was
just a woman
she never been politician she'd never
been active but she died
from this knowledge you don't know what
might happen to anybody
and my safety is of course it's serious
it's important for me for
our son but uh i'm a woman
who was in love is your husband who
lost his husband and i believe i do just
right things
and i believe it okay marina thank you
so much for talking to us